here Bigfoot then I step into the bSpace
rear three he loads the back foot let it
go by this one is free
[Music]
there's his energy but this time I
established a single point so I've got
here on this way I'm on that leg and
he's grounded me on that leg so we're
just grounded here okay did I add the
angle beginning my neck turns would
establish turn and you'll feel that this
is all light his pushing angle he's
passed me you see he's not here pretty
convenient
you pass so that I can step see and I
establish the same single pivot point
there's no weight on this don't have
your center line you line a gravity
between your feet do you see that your
double pivot II single here one pls let
it go past you it's around one
established there's no weight on that
foot I am NOT leaving him there's been
training in that and I am NOT holding it
a constant yield even what he's doing
then you push if I don't you know those
who count even though
[Music]
so mid-foot put this closer whoa whoa
make a small circle and when I do to
bring the hell away and switch the
Bigfoot vector right foot left
left foot right foot stays on the right
whoa goes to the left then back to the
right right left
don't lift me up mm is mr. hunter where
did where's your weight here here push
it push it push it
she's trying to lift a hundred my weight
can see that okay so over here
I go one and you're like you're just
doing IKEA I'm doing the drill don't
change your grip I'm doing a drill
weight goes this way and now I brought
it to my left foot bring it to my left
foot did you know you all lie on
your notebook you don't change your grip
or I will start eating you wool here we
go where do I want wait right off the
right foot you see this way
[Music]
what's happening to your body you can
see it look change it say louder so
what's she trying to do why again why so
she gets lifted up backwards change your
grip again she change the register takes
weight off me I can move wrong grip so
relax come in no go forward
it's surrender back
for for
forward by still a lot of beer except
for my house so calm down
you
this report because I know I need this
letter to come forward and you can't go
like that
and I should be on the record
and you get the mid-foot Vectra on the
outside foot must come in here no
so this foot is free distribution drills
[Music]
so push is she ever going to push me
he's never gonna first you okay I did
not deal because he could push me over
fight in the point is to learn how to
generate maximum force and then create a
situation where the resistance you have
to overcome is minimal do you understand
that okay so I'm not going here because
he wouldn't push me over you could go in
here I step it into free space I still
have a problem a dropping point you see
he's just gonna push into the ground
[Music]
using the ground but where do I want to
create the most minimum amount of
resistance you see so I'm going to take
weight off of his head right now his
feet are supporting his head mass so I
net his feet go past
now I use that power so if you pay
attention when I go here and I hear I
don't make his ego that there I don't
make his head go back there everything
just happens
you see I much I didn't shove his head
back yeah and then I step into this
space I could do it good I don't want
you now that's where the power I didn't
take and make him medically powerful
because I was weak so I don't do that
out of fear
let it go past then in oh right hand
yields you go by oh you're gonna keep
mine because you become like this
while the first time a nightclub when do
I enter yeah after his pushing angle has
passed me that's when I can enjoy when
can I enter what do you think is the
answer so say it when you push it angle
goes past it's not asked me it's gonna
go past me I'm back there
you guys all out and always position
first position first so he goes past me
in an hour
whatever whatever fancy you're thinking
yes you go not here to see live my hit
his have turned his turn he passing me
you see past me that's when I take his
head Tigers
[Music]
it's just easier when he is now pushing
of me and so I don't comes off here
gotta go